you  [Music]  tl first day would be for someone to  come and pick me up and and be like you  know I don't feel like going anywhere  and then I'd be like yeah you're right  let's not go anywhere and then they'd be  like you know what I kind of just want  to go home and watch a movie and I'd be  like all right I'll see you later  this was really fun  [Music]  two subjects never to bring up on a  first date off the top of my head I  don't know babies dying and the Middle  East  [Music]  I think a guy should internet stock the  person as much as they can google the  [ __ ] out of them figure out what their  interests are and then pick something  that falls in line with that  [Music]  [Music]  what was on my high school to-do list I  was a type-a loser  so I had a lot of like figure out how to  dress yourself or figure out how to make  a better ponytail  [Music]  [Applause]  I'm the last person on earth I would  ever go on a date with  [Music]